William asks is there any strategy
behind following thousands of people on
Twitter there's an absolute strategy to
following thousands of people I employ
it I do not consume content that much
from Twitter or if I do I'm thrilled to
get the real stuff along with the
emotional stuff too many people are
utilitarian it's black and white I'm
only going to follow people that put out
good content or things that I'm
interested in because you use it as
truly your news consumption and I think
that's great as a strategy for a public
figure which I am z-list
but I am it's incredible how much it
means to somebody when I go and follow
them and I'm very flattered by that and
I get it because I get super pumped of a
Jets player I freaked out when David
Nelson are you know third fourth
receiver last year followed me on
Twitter because it meant something to me
so I understand it I have the empathy
for that so what is the strategy guys
you've been watching a show or on 27 now
I'm in the depth game
I love the with game and I do a lot of
strategies for it but I'm in the depth
game that's why I'm doing this the
unscalable how many minutes later we for
this uh this taping tonight 15 yeah
right I got real problems right now
things are popping up on my calendar
right now I got problems right now
because it's also a heavy Jewish holiday
and I gotta get the hell out of here
before the Sun comes down or I'm in big
trouble and I'm trying to squeeze in but
I'm in the depth game I didn't skip
today I'm taping for you
because I want to continue to bring you
this stuff you want and you know what's
the stuff you want you want me to follow
you on twitter cuz it feels good because
you get to brag around your friends who
are also into social media or the Jets
or wine or like can't even follow me I
get this as a consumption you know it's
funny I look at stars celebrities they
go on red carpets and they run into
another star that I just bubbled up and
the one person's new so of course
they're a fan of this person but then
they're like oh I'm a fan of you and
they're blown away because they're still
fans we're all still fans no matter who
you are people that are weighing bigger
than me when they find out that I
tweeted them or favorite something or
say something about them they get so
crazy and I'm like you what I mean we're
all fans forever and so there's an
absolute strategy on following a bunch
of people it is about giving them
something they want and when you give
people something they want they
appreciate it
you